so you met charles manson in prison
didn't you what was that story he tells
us
in the county jail but let me tell
charlie wasn't the guy
that you saw on the tv specials
all right he was a ah god he was like
five foot
four or five foot five a little scrawny
he was poor kind of like a bum really
he he had a he had a uh
a string for a belt he tied his
pants with a string because he could
afford a belt
you know and and everybody else we
dressed you know
cool ironed our pen and uh and so the
some of the prisoners were gonna take
advantage of them because they're taking
advantage of anybody it's small
and uh we found out that he could
hypnotize you so we
we let him sleep in front of our cell to
to
you know to make sure that nobody had
heard him and
and uh he got us loaded on weed and
and three other guys in the cell
everybody else had like six guys in
there so we only had three
because we were special
i had two killers with me so so
so uh and then uh
and then he got us loaded on weed and i
said well get us loaded on heroin
so the three of us tried to get loaded
he got two of us loaded on heroin
one guy just woke up and afterwards i
asked him how come welcome he couldn't
do him and he said
he asked did you ever get loaded on
heroin no
well your mind doesn't know how to work
you understand your mind doesn't know
how to react
so if i tell you to do something
while you're hypnotized and you haven't
done it before or you don't know how to
do it
uh you'll just wake up and
that's what kept happening yeah so
you're saying that he got he got you
guys loaded up on heroin weed but there
was no heroin or weed
in the room right he was doing this
purely through hypnosis
people know when i get loaded on heroin
my eyes i get red under my eyes
and that's like literally uh the first
thing you
blah you you throw up you dump and
i mean uh me and chat that was like it's
like we both got
he dumped in the sink i dumped in the in
the toilet
and looked like hey but you know
and oh everybody was like shocked and
and this uh uh uh
johnny ronnie cruz he was like well what
happened
he never got loaded and
and uh ball i kept i you know
i was sorry when they transferred
charlie out
you've basically got unlimited access to
anything that you want because he can
just keep on hypnotizing you back into
it what was he in for do you know why he
was there
yeah i have no idea i have no idea
he was nothing nothing of any you know
he was a petty thief he was he wasn't
you know not to speak ill of the dead
but charlie couldn't have done that
anyplace anytime but right there and my
friend george perry
knew him in frisco knew him in oakland
okay and he was a
he was a uh a scrawny little
hippie and the girls that he
got linda casey all of them were broken
you know they were up in oakland and san
francisco
being ripped off by the pimps and and
raped by the pimps and
and so
he came around with a big bus and some
acid and said you know
let me lead you so it was kind of like
they looked at him like
yeah he's the messiah you know they were
already vulnerable they were already
primed for somebody like him to come in
and say
they were so broken you know so needed
needed somebody to take care of them
in the same way that you could have done
with a bit of extra heroin or weed in
prison
absolutely thank you very much for
tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
makes me very happy indeed peace